welcome everybody
[Applause]
please be seated
distinguished faculty and staff proud
family and friends and honored guests
thank you for joining us here at
Columbia University as we confer degrees
upon cephas wonderful class of 2017 I'm
Cory Wei associate dean for student
affairs an adjunct assistant professor
as Dean of Students it is my distinct
pleasure to welcome all of you to
Morningside Heights as we celebrate the
hard work and the promise of the roughly
750 students who sit before us we thank
the many family and friends some far
away and some present with us here today
who have supported our magnificent
students on their academic and
professional journeys and we recognize
the faculty administrators and staff who
prepared these newly minted graduates to
tackle the most challenging public
policy issues imaginable cephas mission
statement provides that we quote serve
the global public interest by educating
students to serve and to lead my fellow
sepals we are confident that you are
indeed prepared to do just that to serve
and to lead
[Applause]
as you leave Columbia we know that you
will apply what you have learned here to
make your communities your countries and
your world better places we also hope
that you stay in touch with us here at
sefa you are and always will be part of
our Seva family and we hope that you
will visit us often and allow us to
celebrate your ongoing achievements now
it is my privilege to introduce our Dean
Mara J now Dean Jana was a lawyer and
former trade negotiator and appellate
judge she is a globally renowned expert
in international trade and investment
since becoming Dean
she has enhanced all aspects of the
school from academic offerings to the
overall student experience she has
pursued innovative programming and
significantly increased student
financial aid and equally important this
past year she led the university
celebration of FIFA's 70th anniversary
please join me in welcoming our Dean
Mara J now
[Applause]
Thank You Dean way today is a day of
celebration it's a day of reflection I
hope and it marks a significant
achievement in the lives of all of our
graduating students and I want to start
with a special thanks to friends and
family and guests of our graduate who
are here today we're delighted that
you've joined us for this special day
and we thank you for your invaluable
support and encouragement and I would
say to our graduates the family members
and friends who are here today are
amongst those who cherish you the most
and celebrate you the most in this world
and I invite you to join in a moment of
thanks and appreciation to those who
love you
thank you I would also like to
acknowledge and welcome the members of
the sleep of faculty who are with us
today as well as trustees who we all
greatly admire at but most of all we're
here to congratulate the class of 2017
and I would say today marks the
culmination of a journey that began long
before you set foot on this campus and I
think it began with the realization that
you are intensely interested in the
world around you and wanted to further
develop the capacity to make a positive
difference in the world and each of you
has a profound commitment
I believe in knowing many of you to
effective governance to just societies
to learning and contributing to society
to analyzing and solving problems and I
know that you will take those passions
into the world as others before you at
SEPA have done for 70 years in many
different fields in the private sector
public sector nonprofit and indeed
around the world and you came to SEPA
the most global school of public policy
to develop the skills and knowledge to
undertake serious and difficult work and
I believe in the time that you've been
with us you've learned from
world-renowned faculty how to bring even
more analytical rigor and integrity to
the study of complex public policy
challenge I hope that we have offered
you both foundational knowledge in areas
that are critical to the functioning of
our society and economy be it in
international finance or economic and
political development international
security human right
energy and the environment urban and
social policies of course combined with
a study of all regions of the world and
you have acquired both through fieldwork
and Capstone's and internships as well
as through friendships relationships and
insights that will follow you throughout
your career and your lives wherever the
Columbia degree may take you and I think
you've strengthened your ability to
undertake rigorous analysis collaborate
to solve problems engage in civil
discourse you have been part of
searching conversations at SEPA about
diversity and the importance of
tolerance and respect
SEPA faculty and programs are aimed at
equipping you to work with individuals
and institutions to assist those in need
to understand both the importance as
well as the limitations of institutions
whether at home or multilateral and the
power of individuals governments and the
private and non-public sectors to
achieve outcomes that benefit humanity
and as you prepare to depart this great
university in the city of New York I
think a university that is truly
committed to be a center of global
learning and engagement it's natural to
ask are you entering a world that is on
a positive trajectory or one that is
more perilous and unstable with new
sources of risk and uncertainty and it
seems to me that both of those
dimensions are accentuated in this
moment on the one hand technology has
allowed us to be more connected than
ever before scientific capacity is
allowing us to solve problems once
thought well beyond our reach and yet on
the other some post war
institutions are at best under strain or
are coming apart and national boundaries
are being reasserted regional tensions
are on the rise these are but a few of
the problems and issues that we study
and work on at SEPA and it only makes me
feel that our mission and our focus have
become only more relevant and pressing
in the world today
I believe you leave Seba equipped to
address the realities that the next
world order will bring we have
confidence in your ability to meet those
challenges to improve lives and
livelihoods to champion important causes
and to achieve great things in the world
so I hope that you leave here optimistic
because you are remarkable and the world
needs you badly and now it's my pleasure
to turn to the many thank you
we have a few traditions at SEPA that
it's my pleasure as dean to share with
you
we begin our commencement with
acknowledging some of Cephas most
distinguished awards during this
academic year we have a few dimensions
so if I could invite you to hold your
congratulations till I mention them all
but please do stand for those
individuals as I read your names and
awards first I'd like to mention Manya Q
who is the recipient of the Harvey
picker prize for public service for her
exceptional contributions to civic
service both at Columbia and abroad if
you're here please rise I'd also like to
mention Alexander Cox and Isabella
Mathias who are recipients of the
Raphael Smith Memorial Prize for their
essays to be published in SEPA news in
memory of the class of 1994 member
Raphael Smith the dr. Susan Aurelia
gitelson award for human values in
international affairs and the recipients
are Jafar Aslan Sofia Varna Divya
chandran Elizabeth Clark alejandro
hierra Dos Passos Emma Han lj1 drew Ola
mahadji and Renaud up men so thank you
so this is for their workshop project
examining barriers of Workforce
integration for Syrian refugees in
Jordan congratulations
in addition we have the Lewis and Perry
award for progressive sustainability and
the recipients are Sean Bush will Jordan
Jo and kim yong li de bourree pas DAR
and Cameron Toria and this is for their
workshop project policy path to improve
urban air quality in Medellin Colombia
as you can see the range of things at
FIFA is extraordinary
the CAA Campbell Award in recognition of
Bill Campbell chair emeritus and
university trustee and CA a founder goes
to ana gabriela gonzalez
for her many contributions to student
life and service as a dedicated student
leader as a really distinguished by a
spirit of collaboration and partnership
with fellow students faculty and staff
please join me in applause for all of
these prized recipients
thank you I'd also like to recognize two
faculty members who have been honored by
students this year with the outstanding
teaching awards and for small course we
have Betsy apples for her course
international human rights law and for
large course for Lou wikio for his
classes decision model and management
thank you both
it's now my enormous pleasure to
introduce our graduation speaker when we
informally told our graduating class on
who they would like as a graduating
speaker the name David Milliband was met
with resounding enthusiasm and I think
this was the case for a number of
reasons a few individuals combined his
depth of experience as a public servant
and as a leader of one of the most
significant humanitarian relief
organizations in the world he's someone
who is demonstrated throughout his
career and across a variety of contexts
an unwavering commitment to address
serious challenges in areas that matter
to our students human rights the
environment foreign policy migration and
refugees and other areas his skill as an
orator and advocate for important causes
is deeply inspiring David Milliband
currently serves as president and CEO of
the International Rescue Committee an
organization committed to responding to
the world's most troubling humanitarian
crises and helping people whose lives
have been shattered by conflict and
disaster to survive and recover and as
president and CEO he oversees the
agency's humanitarian relief operations
in more than 40 war affected countries
and it's refugee resettlement and
assistance programs in 26 US cities and
under his leadership the IRC has
and its ability to rapidly respond to
manatorian crises indeed in 2016 alone
more than twenty six million people
benefited from IRC programs and those of
its partner organizations in areas such
as primary and reproductive health
vaccinations access to clean drinking
water and sanitation schooling and
education job training and many other
skills from 2007 to 2010 he served as
the 74th foreign secretary of the United
Kingdom in 2006 as Secretary of State
for the environment
he was Member of Parliament from 2001 to
2013 he was co-chair of the global
oceans Commission from 2012 to 2016 he's
a graduate of Oxford University with
first-class honours in philosophy
politics and economics and a master's
degree in political science from the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
his enormous accomplishments have earned
him the reputation in the world of words
of one former American president as one
of the ablest most creative public
servants of our time and as an effective
and passionate advocate for the world
uprooted and poor people were honored to
have him deliver the graduation address
to the class of 2017 please join me in
an enthusiastic welcome to the right
honourable David milligram
thank you very much thank you so much
being Jenelle distinguished faculty of
family friends of the graduates and of
course above all the 750 of you sitting
in front of me I am here for one purpose
above all other today and that is to
offer sincere thanks sincere
appreciation and sincere congratulations
to the enterprising hard-working
eclectic graduate class of SEPA 2017
many many congratulations
I know I know that the standards at
Columbia are high the pace is frenetic
the diversity of classmates from 78
countries is inspiring but I also know
that in graduate studies like this the
expectations are challenging and the
aspirations are limitless all that means
is that the good wishes need to be
heartfelt and I assure you that from me
they are I applaud those of you from
public service for your dedication to
serving your fellow citizens I admire
those of you from the military for your
courage and your service I support those
of you from the private sector who come
here to broaden your experience
I recognize you as fellow mint those of
you from the NGO sector as fellow
members of that sector and I look
forward to what you will bring back to
the non-governmental sector when you
return from here I also want to offer
special thanks to those of you who've
come from abroad to further enrich this
extraordinary city proving every day
that diversity is indeed strength and
although it's Nvidia
I have to say the site of the flags
waved as we came in is one of the most
inspiring things I've ever seen at any
graduation ceremony really fantastic I
will take that image away with me and as
a written who is proud to be a British
but also proud to be European I'm very
glad to see some European flags here as
well but there is one small group of
students from abroad that I particularly
want to call out I celebrate the fact
that there are students here from Sudan
from Iran
from Sudan from Iran from sit from Syria
and also from and also from Libya
[Applause]
clearly your fellow students have made
you welcome but the university has made
you welcome here too and your presence
here today defies the idea that America
needs a travel ban to protect itself
from you your contributors this could be
not a threat
I did my graduate degree
many years ago tragically MIT as the
Dean said and I hope the professor's
behind me don't mind if I say that I
learnt the most from my classmates we
dispersed into academia government
business politics today
the people I met still matter to me and
still guide me so I hope that you find
time to thank each other today as well
as thanking your families and your
professors when the Dean asked me to
come and speak to you I was genuinely
honored to be asked and sometimes you
make a speech just because you're
honored but in this case I actually
wanted to speak to you at this time for
a particular reason there is a fight on
for the shape of our global community
and you and your learning and your
networks and your aspirations need to be
a part of that you need to be leading it
just think of this two years the two
years since you started your courses
have seen massive change in the global
political landscape graduating with a
degree from a school with the word
international in the title suddenly
seems in some quarters countercultural
the word globalist has in a quite
chilling way in some quarters become a
term of abuse I'm sorry to be blunt but
the times are urgent this fight is not
traditional left versus right
although issues of inequality are part
of it it's not West versus rest even
though geopolitics is relevant it's not
even strong versus weak although there
are some surprising alliances it's a
fight for open societies versus closed
multilateral cooperation over unilateral
grandstanding the benefits of pluralism
over the tyranny of groupthink and the
enduring importance of universal values
over those who would slice and dice
populations and
in a fake and faulty attempt to create a
Clash of Civilizations
we're better than that I think you're
better than that to me this is a
struggle for values and insights and
institutions some of which you've
studied that imperfectly uphold the best
of human nature in the face of impulses
and arguments the humor the worst in
human nature one of my great political
heroes was Willy Brandt he was mayor of
Berlin at the time that the Berlin Wall
was built he became Chancellor of
Germany and he wrote this in his memoirs
and I hope you find it relevant today
walls in people's minds are sometimes
more durable than walls made of concrete
blocks I think that's a very powerful
sentiment and it's a challenge that we
face today I see it every day in the
work that I do running a humanitarian
charity working as the Dean said in 30
or 40 war-torn countries around the
world and supporting refugees here in
the United States refugees are caught in
a vise they're running from civil wars
which you'll know are more numerous more
brutal and more extended than ever
before and they face increasingly
hostile conditions when they flee as
international aid is increasingly
inadequate and options for asylum harder
to access let you let me tell you what I
think the International Rescue Committee
has learned over the 85 years since
Albert Einstein created the IRC in 1933
here in New York we've learned that when
countries are confident they are open to
the world they're engaged with the world
they help the most vulnerable beyond
their Shores out of humanity and a sense
of responsibility but also a recognition
that self-interest is involved into
helping others
but when countries are fearful or
doubtful lacking vision and direction
they close up even to people whose
stories would make your heart melt and
that is the situation we face today in
that sense refugees are a weathervane
for the direction of the globalization
that you have studied their symbolic of
the choice we now face to make
globalization fair or to see it in
retreat this is my point to you today
the special benefits of your education
bring special responsibilities at this
time of unusual flux and challenge not
just for Refugees but for all of us on
this crowded inspiring exploited unique
planet your education has been
internationalist keep thinking that way
your education has been
interdisciplinary don't give up on that
the future leaders amongst you will be
able to navigate the public sector the
private sector and the NGO sector your
education has mixed people mixed
students from public private and NGO
sectors hold on to that there are
different insights and your education
has upheld the core idea of a university
that diverse points of view are vital to
good decision-making never let that go
don't think that the people who agree
with you are necessarily right because
sometimes all of us are wrong it's worth
listening to other points of view
I did my degree in public policy just
like you I first took my learning into a
think tank then into opposition politics
then into government as an advisor then
into Parliament then into ministerial
roles and now into the NGO sector I'll
tell you the hardest thing in each of
those roles it's been to keep on
innovating to make time for thinking to
study what your opponents say because
sometimes they're right and we need the
challenge to think more boldly the most
rewarding thing has been to carry on
learning lots of politics and lots of
government is about talking but in my
experience there aren't enough good
listeners in politics the most
successful leaders are really good at
both and I mean really listening not
pretending that you're listening I
thought I would share with you three
reflections on what I would be
prioritizing if if only I was 30 years
younger than I am now
three things that I think are important
not just for you but for all of us the
first is the need to bring back into
harmony the politics and the economics
of globalization because at the moment
they're pulling each other apart when I
went into politics in the 1990s
it seemed that economics and politics
were aligned behind rising wealth and
growing stability the governor of the
Bank of England at the time called it
the nice decayed non-inflationary
continuous expansion today that isn't
the case the global economy is boosted
by migration yet the politics of
migration is tearing Western societies
apart the global economy is stabilized
by international cooperation including
support of creditors to debtors local
politics as the euro crisis shows is
very difficult global politics
mobile economics is boosted by open
trade but we all know having lived in
the US for the last couple of years that
the local politics over trade is in
revolt and global economics demands
investments in the young and Retraining
of the middle-aged local politics is
driven by the high voting rates among
the old unless and until the economics
of globalization starts to serve
majorities not minorities it will suffer
more than a backlash it will be sent
into reverse and our job is to bring the
economics and the politics together the
second reflection is the importance of
learning the right lessons from this
phase of globalization it's easy to see
the failures the scarring experience in
Iraq and Afghanistan and now Libya the
skepticism about the competence of
regulators and the morality of business
because of the financial crisis trade
agreements that are tainted by job loss
but I want to make a different point you
we've got to learn the right lessons of
the successes of globalization and the
need to mitigate the risks of success
not just the risks of failure 75 80
years ago the post Second World War
order set out to expand global markets
and those of you who've come from some
countries as I see in front of me have
good reason to testify how phenomenally
successful that process has been global
GDP has grown 50 times since 1960 but
the result is a major shift in the
balance of economic and political power
with no plan for how to manage that new
balance of power we have to learn the
lesson of that success the post-war
order set out to create a more
interconnected world again it succeeded
beyond wildest dreams but now when we
are inextricably linked in security
health economics we face the reality
that global systems are more and more
vulnerable to shocks from weak links in
the chain where the banking systems that
are
sustainable airport security systems
that are not strong or public health
systems that don't work a connected
world is more vulnerable to those shocks
and finally the post-war order set out
to empower individuals through education
and technology again wild success over
three billion people using the Internet
today but that has left government
institutions looking like dinosaurs in
the digital age and frankly it scares me
that a survey of 6,000 Europeans in
seven countries last month showed that
just half of Europeans aged 16 to 26
believe democracy is the best form of
government at each stage the global
order has sown the seeds of its own
crisis without the stabilizing force of
social justice and effective management
those are the challenges that need to be
addressed today and so my third
reflection is on the importance of
bringing values back into the debate
about our shared future
I like policy so do you so do the people
behind I've been called a policy wonk
the policy without values is barren just
as values without policy lack any impact
the truth is we need to decide what kind
of society we want to be what kind of
humanity we want to be and then find the
policies to deliver it rather than the
other way around
just think of the values that have
defined your education here the equal
worth of each of you as you went about
your daily learning there weren't
special privileges helpful one was
available to all pluralism the
celebration and promotion of diverse
views the essence to me of a stable
Society mutual respect the core of a
university says research and thought
advanced knowledge that knowledge should
be transmitted from one generation to
the next and that facts are different
from opinions
a very famous senator late
now to see senator from this state once
said you're entitled to your own
opinions but you're not entitled to your
own facts you have learned you have
learned that there are not quote unquote
alternative facts there are alternative
opinions we need to fight that that
distinction remains and finally you've
also had at the heart of your education
internationalism not renouncing your
patriotism not putting away your flags
or your identity but refusing to believe
that because you wave the flag of your
own country you need to decry or hate
nationalities people from other
countries people of other nationalities
you will have been taught you will have
been taught in your classes that foreign
and domestic policy are linked and they
are because internationalism is in the
air we breathe literally as well as
metaphorically and every day in the work
I do I see what happens when
fundamentals of equal worth pluralism
mutual respect and internationalism are
under assault children are not educated
women and girls are abused displaced
people are left in limbo so my message
is this don't be afraid of your values
they are your sharpest sword and your
strongest shield in the words of vaclav
havel the former president of
Czechoslovakia and then the Czech
Republic vision is not enough it must be
combined with a venture it's not enough
to stare up the steps we must step up
the stairs remember this for my
generation the Cold War was fought to
break down walls the danger now is the
opposite that new walls
walls as Lily brand said walls of the
mind as well as walls in concrete new
walls defined the first half of the 21st
century in the way that the iron curtain
between east and west defined the second
half of the 20th century and then on the
back of walls to keep people out comes a
vacuum in the international system
weaker institutions more erratic
unilateral actions by countries with the
with the ability to enforce their will
more disorder in the global Commons
that's not a future i won
I believe our job together whatever your
field whether you're going into the
public private or nonprofit sector our
job is to fight against that a world of
connections diversity and compassion is
not somehow cosmopolitan or Western it's
actually the best of humanity which we
need to defend together and that's
something I look forward to doing very
much indeed thank you very much
thank you very much David Milliband for
those very inspiring and important
remarks I'd like to now welcome
Kirsten Mo Hasan who is the new chair of
the CEPA Alumni Association to share a
few words with us Kristin thank you
thank you Mr Miliband and Jean Jane oh
it is my great pleasure to be here today
with the extraordinary class of 2017 to
congratulate all of you and welcome you
as Cephas newest alumni while graduation
woo
while graduation celebrates the awarding
of your degree it also marks the
beginning of your new engagement with
the world beyond
SEPA your Seba education has equipped
you with much of the knowledge and many
of the skills necessary for success but
whatever your objectives ultimately it
will be up to each of you to achieve
your goals I am pleased to tell you that
cephas alumni community can be of help
your SEPA degree entitles you to
membership in a unique network of more
than 20,000 alumni in over 153 countries
all of them united by their shared
experience and their desire to make the
world a better place as the incoming
chair of the CEPA Alumni Association I
welcome all of you as you do this
vibrant and diverse community and
encourage you to stay connected with
each other and with SEPA with this in
mind the CEPA Alumni Association is
pleased to present each of you with a
small graduation gift which will be
available at the reception immediately
following this ceremony we hope that
this memento will evoke fond memories of
your time here at SEPA and will
encourage you to stay in touch and keep
us updated with your contact information
in any exciting personal or professional
developments that you wish to share the
cipa alumni community is eager to know
you and to help you so please stay
involved with SEPA and play an active
in the Alumni Association connect with
fellow super graduates in the online
alumni community participate in Sivas
mentoring program or volunteer to speak
with admitted students come back to
visit at our annual alumni Day or class
reunions celebrate with us at the Global
Leadership Awards Gala and join us for
informed discussions and networking at
any of the CEPA alumni events around the
world most importantly as you embark
upon your newest journey always remember
why it was that you chose to attend SEPA
the remarkable faculty and staff that
helps to guide you the outstanding
students that challenged or inspired you
and the loving family and friends that
stood behind you on behalf of the Alumni
Association and the CEPA alumni
throughout the world we welcome to our
distinguished community and
congratulations again on your
extraordinary accomplishment it is now
my privilege to introduce our next
speaker Thomas Guerra who served as the
president of the CEPA Student
Association
Thomas Thomas graduates today with a
Master of Public Administration degree
in a concentration in urban and social
policy he now plans to continue his
career in the field of Community
Development in his hometown of San
Antonio Texas please join me now in
welcoming Thomas to the podium and to
cephas alumni community thank you thank
you Kirsten
so first and foremost once again we do
not get here alone so it's paramount for
us to show appreciation to the loved
ones here in the audience class of 2017
I'm going to ask for your help in saying
thank you to the loved ones we have here
today
[Applause]
- you loved ones with us today allow me
to shed some light on our experience in
core classes we studied economic
theories and principles along with
corresponding public policies we also
studied international political
structures and institutions of
governance for many of us the content
started to become real
when students from over 70 countries
shared their stories with each story we
were transported to that point in time
and visioned how our lives would have
been different
we leave SEPA today as new vibrant
constellations of those shared
experiences these insights encouraged a
global student body to envision a bright
future take Ashley Montgomery for
example from the human rights and she
yeah from the human rights and
humanitarian policy concentration she
sees a future where gender equality
across the world turns from a
possibility to reality and has dedicated
herself to ensuring that all women are
encouraged and included in the fight for
gender parity
take Daniel Betty Nia Lopez from the
economic and political development
concentration he sees a future for the
European Union including his home
country of Spain where multilateralism
will continue to create opportunities
for peace development and prosperity as
we all look to the challenges ahead we
might need to rely yes haha as we all
look to the challenges ahead we might
need to rely even more heavily on our
sources of inspiration be it family
friends faith or intrusive a style our
drive to tackle and justices now I've
been told that leaning on others is
evidence of weakness but I challenge
that because cheapest students aspire to
dreams that are too large to bear alone
[Applause]
for me one pillar is my husband my
partner or more aptly put in his native
language mo anamcara another is my
community represented here today when my
grandma grandpa mom dad brother and a
constant source of inspiration in my
life my friends their mackaninee look
how far we've come
I'm also driven by my life's calling to
disrupt the intergenerational cycle of
poverty as a minority and
first-generation college and now
graduate student it really took a
village and perseverance to be able to
stand here today what society doesn't
talk thank you
what society doesn't talk about though
is that chronic poverty builds
neurological roadblocks created by the
body as a defense mechanism against
perpetual stressors
this in turn hinders a person from being
able to have control over their own life
I've been blessed to take a closer look
at this during my studies across
Colombia and learned that a major
turning point from my life came from
being gay upon growing up gay I received
threats like if my child were ever to be
gay I would take him out of this world
just as quickly as I brought them into
it as I got older those threats were
replaced by actions with violence
compromising my physical safety I felt
to even have a chance at life I had no
other choice than to forge a path out of
there my desperation at such a young age
to envision a different future and then
identify the obstacles in the way and
strategies on how to overcome them that
was a blessing in disguise that learned
skill was quintessential to
deconstructing the cognitive barriers
developed by poverty and to making it
here today such insights I've already
started using to help dismantle other
systemic oppressions from institutions
policies and even collective norms that
we ourselves perpetuate much credit goes
to professor Fuchs and my USP the urban
and social policy concentration
[Applause]
to my classmates who bravely shared
their similar experiences especially as
part of Adriana's groundbreaking work
published in the Morningside post I
thank you
your strength is another source of
inspiration class of 2017 as we are out
in the world
remember leaning on others is not
necessarily a sign of weakness as vipul
nan de from the International Security
Policy concentration note such things as
the Iran deal may not have happened if
the two head negotiators had not gone
through the same rigorous academic
program I closed
Rica numerating the words from the wise
Yuri from Yuri on ice aspire to dreams
that are too large to bear alone it's
been an honor to serve you president now
congratulations class of 2017
Thank You Thomas you have been a
tremendous leader here and we are
grateful and appreciative it's my
privilege now to welcome faculty and
Dean's to the stage to read aloud the
names of our remarkable class of 2017
and we start with dr. john mutter
director of the ph.d program in
sustainability sustainable development
the first of its kind and a remarkable
group of individuals who join it
dr. mother Thank You Dean jeno I'm very
pleased to be able to introduce you our
seven graduates for this year I
particularly want to thank the the
parents that the partners and pals of
these people who are I think almost all
here today I thought what I might do
just to prove to you how excellent these
people are would to was to read all the
requirements for the PhD in sustainable
development but in the interest of time
I won't to do that and what I will do is
I'll read their names and the title of
their dissertations I'll read them in
the names alphabetically ordered which
is not the way they appear in the
program but let me summarize every
commencement speaker so far that was
reported on in the New York Times save
one noted the unique difficulties of our
times
how fraught we are with falsehoods how
we seem to be diminishing in every
shallowing dialogue the discussions of
the future of the planet what we need
most is people who are consistent
seekers of truth and wisdom and in
general I give you
one of the most arduous ardent seekers
of truth and wisdom the first is Kaley
Berman Campbell whose dissertation is
type of essays on sustainable
transportation considering multiple
modes and land-use anthony D'Agostino
essays in climate and development
economics al frank economic outcomes and
market dynamics of biodiversity loss
[Applause]
Stephani Lackner earthquake ground
shaking and the socio-economic impacts
of earthquakes yeah Kimberly ley aramis
here's the catch
fisheries and fishery management under
climate variability
[Applause]
a rune on view environment and economic
growth and finally Stephan met essays on
the economics of climate change thank
you I'm Eric we're huggin I'm the vice
dean of SEPA it's my great pleasure to
read the names of the graduates of the
Masters in public administration one of
the charming aspects of Cephas this is
one of the most linguistically
challenging taxes tasks that could ever
befall someone in my position wish me
luck
Miguel Acosta
what's up
Toad's bukhari sorry our free use of
lgle Daniel Andrea James Archer
[Applause]
Natasha are dyani David Arnold who knew
Shane Naveed autre Natasha of a nescient
[Music]
[Applause]
sort of being modified
Gerald Baker bhava Priya Giacomo Doty
Mohan
[Applause]
Raul bata
Matteo be doja Zara Bukhari route
cheetah Raja bossy
[Applause]
what I said Rutten Michael Bryan Edward
Burke J clean burns Colvin Danielle
borrow peanut ke Kai Alejandro cock-ups
Gonzalo Deb Castro
[Applause]
been cerini June 5 Chun Divya chandram
Tiffany wait Han Chang raid ouch n hot
teachin
[Applause]
when Tong chin
Cathy yishun chin
Natacha : Alexander Cox
and had a calculation Brenda so young
tween for Cusack
[Applause]
Julianna Damon Yoda Julie and el amante
Rachel de Mars tragedy one Lucia DS D as
Mark Martin working Susan din she proud
dong
[Applause]
Nicholas dounia's Alessandro Passos Jane
Doherty Don Dan wa ali wali de thumb
Kirito she Emma and Nestle Anika I saw
Espinoza Damien Fagan wara and Ferran
Ariana Fishman Arielle Flags Scott fried
[Applause]
Laura Liliana got in Dogen salad see
tiangong sorry val-kill to Shin's
eiegant olga shin way GAO once a typical
silver vegan ana gabriela gonzalez
Gonzalez
[Applause]
Camille gray Jordan Grimshaw Thomas
Craig Gera Rendell Giuliano you jog whoa
[Applause]
cho hyun-ah want to take this one
amnon Hadji Sarah Brodie Hale
[Applause]
[Music]
Bhavya narasimha to see simham work
critical Harris Frederick meeting Herman
[Applause]
Andres Hernandez Fonseca
Sandra an era autumn to un wong
[Applause]
ting-kwong Toby hide Mohammed ear map
Aika Amano
[Applause]
mere Yaya is my Alton Beck is my love 14
job Marsha shall we
[Applause]
Elizabeth Johnson William Jordan sod
Colleen
[Applause]
Sebastian he well Daisuke Kiki moto we
do Kishore
yoshihisa kita Christoph Kramer Radha
Subash Kulkarni Aaron cooler Toma Lisa
Cooney tawa Kentaro Kotani Shin why
[Applause]
Nessa rothorn lolly guanine school
Mariana left Patricia the tape gently
[Applause]
finale young Jenny Lee Ying Ying Lee
ung-yong
[Applause]
Andrew you finally Jing Yi Liu Ming
Cheng Liu see you you shall do
[Applause]
eating Lou
Andrew long Higgins David low way Lou
whoa Robert Marshall
[Applause]
Jimena Motta's antenna
Sayaka matsumura zouri anomalous
[Applause]
we men
Colleen metelitsa Bobby Scheck me Tom
[Applause]
Catherine mo
zapping Moo other swoony Tyler Cameron
Linton Mohammad timer Mustafa Avanti
Narayana Aurelio I'm around
[Applause]
Janani Natarajan
Charlotte nursin Teresa need early
[Applause]
Matthew O'Brien Gloria oh hell yes arrow
leave our it Haruna oh no Tara pandal I
[Applause]
drew Pandi
Priya pari Isabella Perales signora
[Applause]
Stanislav pond or the u.s. we pulled our
Sardar Pola any Pope Gaurav Pradhan
[Applause]
Brandon more sell Spencer premium chew
on ching chang you KU Leuven Ramon
[Applause]
Santiago Ramirez Isaac route certain
things are permitted of former Dean's of
SEPA Progressive Party Mirada
[Applause]
[Music]
Loretto del Pilar raise revenue arrow
Sofia Rivas Sergio Sergio Rodriguez Tom
Rollerson how wrong alia saga and Yoko
de holanda Cova can is Fatima Sahib
[Applause]
Indrani circa Raphael Fletcher
Daniel snog Anthony Scott Lubner Chara
[Applause]
Prerna Sharma
Elinor she Stephanie she waning shoe
[Applause]
Clara Sierra Nevada Rocha Ericsson soon
young son
[Applause]
Hana song
haan-soo Maria cirilla Sonya Nina suitor
[Applause]
minuted Rishi Kasumi takahashi
seelix ton Ingrid Tang ye Feng Teng use
one Tang Soo man tarik Margaret Thomas
[Applause]
Michelle Maria Thomas yuan Tian
Lena Torres say that Turks ever Danielle
Oh Urbina Christian Vande working Sergio
Verdugo Montenegro Sam Schneider Gayatri
Vijaya Raghava how one one how
[Applause]
May one with a one honey on why mattias
fire
[Applause]
Jamie Welch min when Christopher Kirk
Wessling
[Applause]
ginger Whitesell yawen whoo true lin
xiao shu young zu you young use of
Yahoo's tire year Mack paya Pienaar yet
can go KO maan yuck you
[Applause]
Jane you
Sydney's a tomb
[Applause]
ray chang-su hunt run chuan zhang you
want one jeong-hwan you job
[Applause]
way gel
edye gel last but not least Maisie Jing
[Applause]
good afternoon my name is bill emic and
I'm the director of the picker Center
for executive education and is my great
honor to introduce the 17th graduating
class of the executive master's program
and public administration
[Applause]
manal al Shaquille camerea Braithwaite
yo lon
khador hero che che Michael Chang Megan
Decker Timothy dental I'm Sarah Elsa
paui
Eric Espen Berg Barbara Fritchie Josette
gomez Brandi Allen henyk jr. Ibrahim
Hashim oj jolly ki Yong Yong
Angela john g jolly Jang Eleonora Jane
Rosenthal Khan mark Kim
[Applause]
John Paul Lauren hi Angie Lee pong lay
all m---eleven ying li amber Liang Xu
Chen Lin Monique
Lopez Amy Lou
Alan e McCord
Byron Tyler Mako Lorraine Martin
Mustafa Masuda Julie Marino kerela
Delphine
Milou kike Mohan
Diana matzo lab Killeen Montero
[Applause]
Cindy Amelie Moran
Misha lose Moran Milan Navy Tomei nikich
le Prado Nieto Shiki nori
Gisela Paiva Nicholas Porter
Emily D Ramos Lucia Rodriguez Ricardo
Rodriguez
Kaitlin Barnett Sherman willin bueno
Silva Sofia
Sunwoo Asiata Harish Tuzla Jeffrey
blasquez Monica Vienna
Maurice Wiggins
George whoo David John Zang on war
giardini Zuria Clark Zoo
[Applause]
good afternoon I'm Glendenning I'm I'm
the director of the MPA and development
practice and it's my pleasure to
introduce our sensational seventh cohort
the MDP class of 2017
and I begin with Molly Adam laughs my
Sheikh Ahmed Paul Alex
[Applause]
Roger
Nathaniel Ashby oppa Ava's a Atari
[Applause]
Henoch gilma big ashore
Chiara
Burcu Rachel Berman Roberto burn Ally
[Music]
[Applause]
John bitumen Mohammed boxia Ross captain
Yara tongue DeWitt dummy Sofia David
Francisco gmez cisterna Paul goo Keisha
Herbert
[Applause]
Farida o Ibrahim Maurice Ezekiel Jackson
Josh Jacobsen penny Jayanti
Veronica Chuck would them giddyap
Gideon whoa David Joe
[Applause]
Monica Johnson
Morgan Johnson Trisha Johnson Erika
Francis Jordan Heather Callahan
[Applause]
Alicia fan Julia King Jenny Lee
Caroline Logan Ashley McQuarrie Tommy
subtly Merkin
[Applause]
John Massey Laura or Choa bikini sama
Othman magna Filippo Christina Heidi
Perez Gonzalez me here Prakash
[Applause]
Chandni Punia Juan Manuel who Jana cobby
rum burn
[Applause]
Valley earlier Sano
Alissa shoemaker Aditya subramanian
[Applause]
Elena Valerie
Chiaki Pisciotta Nicolas Toro Arboleda
[Applause]
Gary Verburg Elena Vilela Tabari
Aishwarya vishweshwara
[Applause]
Chalam Quan Newt Warren it yep
Yin Zheng Yi good afternoon I'm Leigh
John McCauley and I'm honored to
introduce the 2017 class of graduates
from the program on economic policy
management this is a group that you
should know is about 50 students from
about 26 different nationalities so
talking about diversity and so I want to
congratulate all of them and I will
start them within the names
Nana Zika are yevo Kali Luba
[Applause]
I took a low blow to have saya magical
it is empirical Sara baaji Alfonso
Caravaggio Paris and and family J sin
[Applause]
that we'd tell Quadro simmerman Jackson
that
I polled araguari Liam motivation when
he had very good dumb sack
[Applause]
no Jack River
mohamad ages
anga a kanata Hisham l-haqq gg ROFL
Buddha ya go Alberto granado's Alonso
why you know
[Applause]
konnichi even
[Music]
[Applause]
kimitaka Katehi ibrahim combiner Hanna
Kim Hiroyuki Coco type Teresa lamenting
[Applause]
cloudy early so Alaska
estefania lupito
Mecca Malik
[Applause]
Lucas Martin Zhi Ming Hong Kong me
Srinivas Raja Carolina Grenada sinners
and fault
[Applause]
Abdul Rahman she - Lydia sim Bangala
Robert sunken life
[Applause]
Kazumi Fujimoto lease retinol quest evil
psyche
Susheela
[Applause]
Nicholas furnace tracky one young one
yeah yeah Kumar yeah a see and yeah cool
Zak
[Applause]
my name is Keith Cohen please
please welcome our newest group of
sustainability professionals critically
needed to protect the global environment
in this perilous time the environmental
science and policy class of 2017
starting with Mohammad Ashdod Kai Chen
[Applause]
see you Chen
Lauri CEO child me Rob Cohen Daniel cook
[Applause]
Sierra Cunningham
Jonathan do Billy a jingjing do
[Applause]
President Kevin fertig Caitlin Flay hi
Alexey gitelson
Jia Chen Judy go
[Applause]
Erica Golan kanwa
Nina George's Nicole Joseph Sarah
Ghidorah sigh you coo coo boat era un
Lou lacy McCarthy Katherine McNamara
Elizabeth Medford
sue Mara Mara Savannah Miller Xenia
Montero Alison pace Neera de Peau Duvall
Caillou Cho hun care road McKenzie
Schwartz
[Applause]
Danny skull tippity sealer Marisa
sterling nah
sue arena SUSE Joe pop Mazda Shawn toca
may have eye gunk ur Jason then Busey
can
[Applause]
Roselyn Venables Yara essentia Abril
Wicklund Isaac Wilkins Emily yawn Shira
Yatta
you
[Applause]
[Music]
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen my
name is Jim Ferranti and I'm delighted
to present the degree the candidates for
the degree of masters of International
Affairs Mona Sultan Alice my inaud
Tariq I'm Jed
[Applause]
Olivia arguin zonie Zora day Arius Jafar
Aslan Igor Barkov Cydia Balakrishnan
[Applause]
Shriram Balasubramaniam Megan Barrera
Marcelo Barrera
[Applause]
Lydia Vasiliy Serena Bellamy
Ignacio Bellini Virginia Benin casa
[Music]
[Applause]
Ariane been re3 all but Marcel back
Emily wha tell Emma born Yas Ellis
Bosley Sophia Maxwell Burton Sean
Christopher Bush jr. Lydia Cano Pedro
Roma have yo me karti juelio Catherine
City
Henrietta Tucker kevin chen
Don Lu Cheng tsingy ciao
[Applause]
joseline Chu Sherman to marry Chun
Charlie Chung tahir chichi Elizabeth
Clark
[Applause]
Jennifer Cohen Miranda Vera Cohen
Adam Cole
Daniel combs Christina Constantine
Joseph CERN it's Cassidy daily yes Mina
da da de jorge de bourguignon
[Applause]
Kendall Durst n Tom Dueck GEVO door
obits
bihaan dong Cheng Cheng du Quentin
Dumont Clippard do wrong
Nico esta Theo a la al shop a Kevin
Ivo dune mashallah
a yonder Francis Raquel Frederick
Victoria gate on Jenga Denise goal
[Applause]
Christopher good
Eduardo granny so Torres Marisol
growl blah de Gras mova Nealon Jonna
Gupta kokuto Han
Mariko Hannity Tara's a US Army knee
[Applause]
aquila Hines Dylan Hoover
Rachel javi Rachel
Yuki okawa Leo Isaac
Dhoni --n j one Jew ylan Ilya carnico
[Applause]
Patrick Kelly Kirsten Kiril Pierre de a
lot in kilink
[Applause]
Bomi
Kim
[Applause]
hojoon kim jiwon kim Akiko kobayashi
deflation clevy Sacco Bochy Nikita Kumar
[Applause]
kr quo the manual Lavoie man Lin Sarah
Linde
[Applause]
Thomas Lynde
[Music]
[Applause]
cheryl-lea chung view Rita
lo Diego Sebastian Juha Velasquez
dan Louie replaces him Linden
lo ye Lu can Luo Rachel ekoo Macaulay
congratulate Chris may hum Tushar Malik
Coralie Martin Patrick Martinez
[Applause]
resolution Thank You Stephanie
double Stephanie Martinez Reinhardt
Albert mattone dong
[Applause]
Jeremy McCann
timbi Medici Isabella Macias Mary Coe
Meyer Joe Christine miles
[Applause]
[Music]
Aman Mita
[Applause]
hola Mohajir chipmunk on shia
rania Ashley Montgomery
[Applause]
Ameen Mousavi Lisa Anouk muler doorman
Matus Miren
[Applause]
Anna Wanjiku Gertrude Wender Yasuko
Nakajima Whipple nigh and Oh Laura nears
Bach show Hey Nishimura and Kristina
Novak Andre
Oh Joe uh to ASSA
[Music]
Sandra Oh Pauline Fiona on Marcos paya
[Applause]
Daniel Pepe Nia Lopez one parade all
James Phinney been pibil Sangram
[Applause]
Jonathan PK Ashley Marisa party Oh
[Music]
Daniel prelate Chen malaria Ramirez
Schiller
[Applause]
Anala Ravana Ryan Nicholas Reinhold
Raphael ring cone Alexander row Jennifer
Robards Aaron Paul Roth Jason Russell
[Applause]
are mere Safa and mrs. Roxana sapphire
they are married
Cobin Sakurada a Beatrice Santa would I
[Applause]
get Safavieh Lucia
Sobchak Matthew David Schiller
Marlene Schreyer David Sadowski Eden
Sela Danielle Masha Selby
anirudh Sharma
Jung will see
Edna Simbi Alexandra Solomon Rena
[Applause]
seung-ki or geese ULA's ad Joshua
Schwartzel Adriana Tom K Robert Tarun
[Applause]
Matt Terry Tabitha pilgrim Thompson
Camryn Torreon Neil i-tunes joke
[Applause]
Niko's buzanis Michael vinter marie van
haften Roberts Wesley Alexandra Maria
Wilcox
[Applause]
Madeline Wahlberg Emma
Xiao Jing Zhu Michael Zucker Phil Zhi
[Applause]
Bing seung-joo and ladies and gentlemen
please join me in congratulating all of
our graduates the Columbia sefa class of
2017 ladies and gentlemen thank you for
joining us today please remain seated
until the graduates have egrants